you all know that i am a hip-hop maven
probably the pop culture voice of our
generation and there's a new song out
that i really wanted to listen to
watch for the first time and review in
real time the song is by an artist named
tom mcdonald you might be familiar with
him i i realized
now i've reviewed
six of his songs
fake woke in god we trust brainwashed
new world order snowflakes and america
and tom has been insanely popular but
the gatekeepers who control the lists
and the charts and all that kind of
stuff they try to suppress it which i'll
get to a little bit later but he's got a
new song out it's called names
it it just came out it's got 2.3 million
views in just the first few days and i
thought you know i've done so many of
these songs
and i assume i am 100 correct in my
interpretation of every single moment
but just just in case just to maybe add
a little bit of color here
i figured it was time we brought on tom
himself tom thank you so much for coming
on the show
hey thanks for having me man so
i'm i'm gonna i'm gonna need you to gut
check me here a little bit you know if i
go off the rails a little if i'm
misinterpreting something i
i think for the for the seventh song you
know that's a that's a great n that's a
perfect number i i want to hear it from
the horse's mouth so without further ado
let's play names
they gon try to call you names label you
with things till you're ashamed you're a
sexist or a racist white supremacist or
gay they'll attack your reputation claim
that you're the one to blame and try to
make you hate yourself for ways that you
behave they're just names embrace them
and they'll never cause you pain they're
just words that another person thought
up in their brain they're just names
they do not define you that's insane and
they'll just call you something
different if you change
call me racist i don't make no blm
donations i can stand with black folks
without a branded corporation all this
systemic prejudice
so two things i want to get to there the
i get to the second one first
you you tie blm
to corporations
and
i love that because the way that blm
presents itself it's that it's the
counterculture it's just the natural
voice of the people speaking up against
institutionalized power but then when
you look at it for two seconds you
realize wait a second all the most
powerful institutions in the country
especially the corporations they're the
ones bankrolling blm
i think
distorting like the line says i can
stand with black folks without donating
to a branded
to it to a to a to a corporation um and
i think that for you know
i think it started off innocent enough
and it had sort of like a a a sentiment
behind it that a lot of people sort of
co-signed at the time
and the further down that road we got
the more pressure there was to
go to a protest donate money do this do
that put this on your instagram and if
you don't do these things then you're a
racist yeah and it's just it got you
know it's just
look i don't have to donate to to blm
and i think that a lot of people that
have donated to blm
now were
two years removed from its inception
probably regret the fact that they did
um with all of the things that have sort
of come out about that movement uh over
the past couple years so you know so
that one to me is like pretty
self-explanatory
i can stand with black folks i can stand
with with uh with people who feel like
they're marginalized without um without
fueling a corporate machine yeah and and
frankly
the more you fuel the corporate machine
probably the less you're standing with
people who would say are
called themselves marginalized or
oppressed or something like that i mean
you look blm raised what 90 million
dollars how much of that money went to
george floyd's intimates how much money
of that went to
people who were well there were a lot of
george floyd family members who came out
of the woodwork he probably never even
met them there were a lot of race
hustlers and professional politicians
and activists who made a lot of money
patrice culler's bought a lot of nice
houses in california with that money but
how much of that money actually went to
the marginalized and the oppressed not a
not a red cent of it not at all and i
really like that the first line of the
song too you you say look they're all
these names that people throw at us and
you use all the names that they throw at
the right wingers homophobic racist
dysphobic this phobic but then and you
say we're gay
and i like that too because gay
is a line that well it's not even really
partisan it's just the sort of thing you
call someone when you're in third grade
like oh man you're so gay that's so dumb
that's so stupid and so that's one that
it kind of cuts against the idea that
you're just putting out right wing
propaganda
well absolutely that was the point
that was the point and i also knew like
uh i knew what i was asking for by doing
that too because there was a lot of
people who stood up and said like
uh you're homophobic because you said
gay
uh
in the context of all of these other
horrible names that you used and to me
it's just like
the whole point of using that word where
i used it just went so far over so many
people's heads
they're so
uh
obsessed with having something to be
angry about that instead of for two
seconds
sitting back for a minute and being like
okay
why
why did he use that word there instead
of having the conversation or asking the
question it's just immediate attack
attack attack people calling me
homophobic which is essentially what the
song's about the names that people call
you so it's just
yeah i had a debate once with not not
that long ago with a friend of mine
who is definitely a little bit light in
the loafers you know he's not exactly
into the chicks and we were having this
whole discussion about whether or not
science is fake and gay and it occurred
to me you know someone would probably
come in if they overheard that
conversation and say you're you guys are
homophobic and you know it'd be of
course up to their ignorance that
uh this guy is uh he's the first part of
that word it's not you know not the
there's no phobia going on at all okay
let's keep going
prejudice if you live in this nation you
privileged black or caucasian
call me transphobic but i support you in
your policies i just can't ignore the
very basics of biology all i see is men
and women trying to live in harmony not
a hundred genders that you wanna be
call me snowflake cause i'm offended i
ain't stone-faced social justice
warriors destroying us with ways mad
because they voted for the potus with
the most hate
man i miss the old days call me loser
call me bigot call me stupid call me
bitter call me ugly call me cracker call
me douche call me trigger you can call
me what you want cause at the end of the
day
man
they're just names go ahead
let's put a pause there
the the
the transgender aspect to this i think
is really interesting because the whole
thesis of the song is
it really doesn't matter what you call
me i know that those things aren't fair
or true and so whatever call me whatever
you want i'm rubber your glue you know
it bounces off of me and it's no big
deal
but
i think it was a little more poetic than
that though it was a little more poet
yeah it was like when george w bush he
said fool me once shame on you fool me
twice uh the point is you're not gonna
fool me again but you know the but it
the the flip side of the names issue
is obviously transgenderism because the
the transgender debate is all about
names whether or not i am forced to call
a dude who thinks he's a woman she
and her and use some fake woman's name
instead of his actual name the the flip
side of this is that the transgender
argument says if you do not call me the
names that i demand that you call me if
you do not constantly affirm whatever
delusion i've got
you are destroying my existence you
might as well kill me that the the names
you call me are the most important
things in my life and you think well
you're
you've just flipped it 180 degrees from
from reality from the iron rubber and
you were glue
right so yeah that's that's pretty much
that that line in the song that was uh
uh call me transphobic um
i support you and your policies i just
can't ignore the very basics of biology
like to me like that whole thing is just
that like
i don't
have any problem
uh with
trans people or people that want to
define their their own genders and live
in that world and do that whole thing
it's just at some point
along the way here i have to draw the
line somewhere and say hey like
here is where i stopped participating
in this charade that you guys like i
like
it it
inevitably it comes to an end somewhere
so for me
that's like if you want to go do that
over there and go do your thing fine i'm
gonna i'm gonna do my thing over here
i'm not gonna interfere with you guys
don't interfere with me don't force me
to
when you start saying things like if you
misgender somebody it's a crime it's
against the law to misgender somebody or
words are actual violence when you start
saying things like this
that's a slippery slope man like
you're going to end up in a real gnarly
situation when
when misgendering somebody becomes a
crime right ironic of course because the
only people misgendering anyone are the
are the people who want they want us to
call the men the women and vice versa so
right then things do get very gnarly all
right keep going
your words ain't gonna hurt us anymore
[Music]
label you with things till you're
ashamed repeat it till you really start
believing what they say they gonna stamp
it on your forehead and scream it till
you break they love to say they woke
they not awake
they're just names afraid of anyone who
ain't the same so they classify your
thoughts it's controversial not okay
then they cancel you till everything you
have all gets erased they trying to tell
the world you bet they're just names
call me conservative or liberal that's
pleasant right there so i i love that
line you know
say whatever you want i just hope you
find the lord you know i'm getting bored
of this but i i really love that and i
wonder
i don't even know if this was a
conscious choice but that little line in
there
then brought up this image
for me when when you get to that next
verse where you say look they're going
to call you names and they're going to
cancel you and they're going to come
after you and they're going to try to
destroy your life and they're really
going to they're really really going to
hit you
it it actually this is going to sound
like i'm being hyperbolic here or making
a stretch but but go with me it sounded
it it brought up this image to me of the
trial of christ it brought up this image
to me of the passion of christ where he
goes he's brought up on trial and they
say they accuse you of this they say
you're a blasphemer they say you did
this and you said this and you do this
and you just and
jesus just remains silent during all of
that and when people ask him direct
questions did you are you the king of
the jews he says well you say that i am
that's what you say i don't you know
you tell me you're the one who says it
and it i don't yeah i don't know i mean
that the timing of those two lyrics
seems
uh
if it wasn't intentional it certainly
works
well yeah i can tell you for sure that
um
uh the timing of the video versus the
lyrics wasn't intentional but to me the
overall
uh throughout the whole video i think
sort of
what you're explaining um
i was crucified on that billboard
uh to me
like all of those billboard scenes those
were like very biblical and we're so
we're supposed to be a reference to sort
of um uh
to jesus you're crucified on this
billboard there's all these names
written up on the billboard that people
say that you are all the arrows are
pointing at you and to me it's just the
whole sort of sentiment of the song is
like okay if if you say i am then
then fine yeah you say whatever you say
you you can't right no there's a there's
a line in i think it's the
memoirs of frederick douglass
where he he describes
being
insulted and degraded and all you know
all these
terrible lines are thrown at him and he
says you're actually not degrading me
you you can't degrade me by calling me
names and telling me to go different
places and you just don't have the power
to do that i can degrade myself in how i
react to you but you just throwing all
that bile at me
you can't take away my dignity
absolutely and i think that there's
definitely something to be said for um
you can take all of the ridicule and
uh humiliation and embarrassment and
anger
and frustration and you can take all of
these things that people
throw at you in life
especially in the the last few years um
i i feel like you can take all that
stuff and you and you can turn it to
power
you can use that stuff as fuel
um and i think that
when you have the opportunity to put
those types of things in a music video
it's almost like holding up a giant
mirror
and all of those people that are calling
you those names and throwing that hatred
and um just spewing that sort of like
rhetoric at you i feel like they have to
like look in the mirror when they see it
uh in visual form in a music video i i
think it causes a lot of like sort of
self-examination from these people and i
mean
i
if one of those people sees that music
video and thinks oh my god
he's right
i've been being an [ __ ] i feel like
that's accomplished
right of course and and the the uh
crucifixion imagery is is really apt
because there is this christian idea
that suffers at least a catholic idea
and in particular the catholics have
this uh this sense that suffering is
sanctifying that suffering or at least
it can be sanctifying that when people
are doing all sorts of terrible things
to you and they're inconveniencing you
and they're calling you names and
they're attacking you that we should
kiss it up to god that you you kind of
take that on you it binds you in a way
to to christ and you say okay i'm not
i'm not gonna complain about it i'm not
gonna whine and scream and i'm not gonna
debase myself
you you call me all those things okay
you said it you said it what can i say
i'm not i'm not going to degrade myself
here let's keep going
me conservative or liberal republican or
democrat i'm somewhere in the middle but
y'all don't know what to do with that
the system got you so obsessed with
classifying right or left you never call
a person human call them names instead
call me sexist i love that pause so now
you're addressing
something that i know there's been a lot
written about you when it comes to your
politics are you right-wing are you left
wing
are you
you certainly kind of you look in some
ways a little more left wing you know
you got you got some tattoos you got uh
you know you're not wearing a brooks
brothers suit and an ill-fitting tie or
something like that uh but in some ways
you also look
more right wing you don't look like some
shrimpy kind of you know hipster at a
cafe eating uh
avocado toast or something like that so
i even when you look at you you say i
don't know if you're left or right and
then
the libs have accused you of basically
just grifting and saying that you're
just going to make a quick buck by by
sounding right wing but the libs also
attack you constantly for your songs so
i don't know they're not exactly
straight on their story so what is it
you say in the video i'm not exactly
left i'm not exactly right i'm not a
republican i'm not a dick so what is it
yeah um
i feel like i'm definitely uh i like to
consider myself a free thinker and i
think that that that more often than not
um that
causes me to land
slightly right of center
to be completely honest i think that the
people on the right side of the spectrum
um i think they have sort of the best
idea of
what's going on in the world right now
uh i think they have sort of the best
ideas on how to move forward to make
things better um
and i think that's probably
a big part of the reason why they've
been
beaten down and humiliated and canceled
and silenced and censored and bullied
uh by the the the left-wing media and to
me it's like
i grew up
i grew up as a loner my whole life
i hung out by myself i was always kind
of like a weird kid and i was a
skateboarder and got piercings and got
tattoos and
and and you know
i was the underdog as a kid and and you
think that like uh when you're bullied
as a kid oh well one day i'm gonna grow
up and nobody's gonna bully me anymore
and then you grow up
and the bullies get bigger and meet
louder and more intense and to me
that is the liberal media and the left
side of the spectrum right now so
i
tend to stand a little right a center
with the people who are getting bullied
because i identify with that
just unpopular opinions are as valuable
if not more valuable than whatever the
mainstream narrative is at the time
so
well it actually it kind of gets back to
the religious imagery in the
in the music video which is uh
you know sometimes people will complain
they'll write into the show and they'll
say michael i just want to speak the
truth but people keep attacking me for
speaking the truth i say
uh-huh yeah do you remember what they
did to socrates uh remember what they
did to our lord and savior who is the
truth himself remember what they did to
uh pretty much everyone who's ever
spoken the truth uh ever in all of human
history
like if that's not the the age-old story
of good versus evil man like
you know
when you when you try to do something
good when you try to do something
righteous uh when you try to do
something pure that's when the demons
and the evil and the badness come out of
the woodwork it's just the way that it
is yep yeah that's true you can you can
count on that all right let's keep going
i'll be sexist men run the world cause
they're aggressive but behind every man
there's a woman just as successful we
will never be equal in every way that
ain't helpful our differences are why
we're great together
call me white devil i know you think the
system favors me my privilege is
residual benefits from the slavery
subconscious prejudice embedded in this
system made for me don't mean i never
struggled to survive i guess we ain't
agree ignorant and jaded call me dumb
uneducated call me idiot or redneck or
delusion don't look crazy call me
anything society has taught you to say
cause at the end of the day they're just
[Music]
names anymore
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
stupid
loser
ugly
[Music]
[Music]
really like that the stupid
loser
poser all that because
it opens up with
racist sexist homophobic all these words
that actually are thrown at people in
their adult lives
and you
you tie it in or
later on in the song with the the kind
of the same taunts that you get when
you're in second grade
and uh and and there's no difference i
mean the p you say the the bullies don't
go away they only get bigger they give
you a swirly when you're in second grade
and then they try to kill your job and
you know kick you out of school or your
place of employment when you get older
and it's just as mean-spirited it's
really more mean spirit i mean there's
nothing worse that you can be called in
today's society than racist so okay
you're going to do that you're going to
come at me fine just call me a big dumb
ugly loser like you like you would do in
second grade and at least be honest
about it
totally well that well that was sort of
the
uh you know when we start we started off
that bridge section with your sticks and
your stones which is sort of like the
i'm rubber your glue thing yeah so it
starts off with this very
like adult grown-up version of like what
these bullies are and over the course of
the three minutes it's sort of
degenerates into
you loser ugly stupid [ __ ] like it sort
of degenerates and to me though that's
that that's the whole thing unraveling
and falling apart and destroying itself
from within until you're left with
nothing but second grade insults that
we've all heard before you know that's
right and that actually do bounce off of
me and stick to you when you jerks throw
them at me absolutely all right let's
keep going
[Music]
i just love that the guy that's calling
you those names just is the guy i
described in the coffee shop with the
avocado toast
i didn't know that i haven't seen the
video yet but that's really
that's really excellent that's artistry
okay keep going
[Music]
yeah yeah i really enjoyed that
so before i let you go tom this is very
good this is very cool it's very trippy
to review a song in front of the artist
because if that song had been terrible
it would be very awkward for me you know
i'd have to i because i don't i can't
lie i'd have to be i'd have to try to be
polite like oh i really like the
costumes you know and uh but anyway
because like i said michael i'm a big
fan of what you do so this would this
could have been heartbreaking for me
super awkward for you yeah
just it just ends up being a 10 minute
video like uh well anyway so before i
let you go though tom i
i do want to get to the
sales numbers because you're i know that
your songs have been extremely popular
i have been stopped in bars i'm not
kidding i've been stopped in bars around
the country and people will come up to
me to say
michael so nice to meet you and i think
oh great they're going to talk about how
much they love my show they're going to
say maybe they love my books or
something like that and they say michael
i'm not joking this actually happened to
me so michael tom mcdonald has a new
song out when are you going to review
that that's my favorite content on your
channel so when are you guys like i'm
what am i tom mcdonald's publicist over
here i got but so i know your stuff is
very very popular
the people who put the charts together
i noticed they sometimes leave your name
off of them what's that about
dude uh there there's been a plethora of
different ways that we've sort of uh
butted heads with with the music
industry and and their reporting systems
and giving us the credit we deserve so
you know it's happened in a variety of
different ways we uh uh
we had a video trending at
like number five or something on youtube
uh a few months ago so if you went to my
actual video on youtube underneath the
video it says trending at number five
and then you go over to the trending
charts and the charts go one two three
four six
like five has been completely omitted
from the charts
um and i just released a collaboration
album a few months ago with adam calhoun
where um
we did like 45 000 units or something um
and
and
that was that that was physical copies
and the reporting system
refused to count our physical sales
which would have essentially like locked
us in at the number one spot on the
albums charts and we went back and forth
with these people for
weeks and weeks and weeks and weeks and
were like we were at the point where we
were like begging them
what can we do for you guys i just don't
get it because it's it seems to me look
i don't what do i know about selling
musical albums but it seems to me it
would be much harder to sell physical
albums than it would be to sell a
digital download and so you're you're
selling the physical units and what they
just they just don't believe you they
think you're lying or something
yeah and it got to the point where
this is unprecedented and uh extremely
dangerous uh for me to do but i offered
them
a username and a password so that they
could sign in to the back end of my
commerce wow and buy all of the units
sold themselves and
they wouldn't do it
wow and we figure out why so
but that's just that's just you know the
nature of the entertainment industry man
it's uh you know it's uh incredibly uh
it's an incredibly woke
sector of of music is an incredibly woke
sector of the entertainment business and
um
and i don't i don't fit the the mold
they want uh they want britney spears
they don't want dennis rodman you know
what i mean
i guess that's probably true i also now
that you've made that comparison i can't
unsee it i had never made that
comparison before so
that's really frustrating but it is to
be expected the new york times did a
similar thing when my book came out last
year speechless we sold and it's even
it's much easier to track
these things in book sales and we sold
40 percent over the number one new york
times bestseller that week and the sales
continued for in the following weeks
we sold i think an order of magnitude
more sale or more copies than people
lower down on the list they wouldn't put
it on the list
anywhere and they're protected from that
because and they've said this in court
their best seller list is editorial
content so if they don't like a book
or i assume the same principle holds if
someone doesn't like a movie
or a a movie shirt or a tv show or a
song or an album they can just keep it
off of the list and we were lucky that
publishers weekly publishes a
a list that accurately reflects sales so
they put us at the top of that one but
the the cartels that that are the
gatekeepers to this kind of cultural
content they don't they don't want you
to be getting the numbers that you are
getting and you're getting them anyway
and it makes it all sweeter so
tom for though for the handful of people
maybe who don't already subscribe to
your stuff where can they find you
uh so on instagram i'm hangover gang uh
on youtube it's youtube.com slash tom
mcdonald official facebook.com
mcdonald official twitter uh slash i am
tom mcdonald if you just cert put my
name in on any of these platforms you'll
find me and hundreds of thousands of
people talking about me i'm really easy
to on the internet
that's great absolutely so you can head
on over there subscribe next i'm going
to start working on my rapping abilities
so that i can someday audition to be in
one of these songs because that would be
really trippy for me to review the song
with me you know in it i have i have to
say i'm not the most fluent rapper yet
but if i keep listening if we keep doing
these reviews maybe i'll maybe i'll be
able to improve a little bit in the
future so are you are you planting the
seed right now for for tom mcdonald
featuring michael knowles i am listen i
have very few
specific career goals
left you know that i really oh i
generally i just kind of i just kind of
go with the flow man you know i kind of
see where politics but this one this is
up there it is on the chart
so we'll see we'll see where it goes you
know okay
tom absolutely fabulous well fabulous to
really meet you for the for the first
time actually talking beyond just you
know a dm here or there and uh really
great stuff keep it up keep pissing off
all of the right people it's a real joy
to watch them sputter and pull their
hair out and run their garments and
gnash their teeth thanks for coming on
man thanks man it was a total pleasure
[Music]
[Music]
you